voilà monsieur bonsoir bienvenue au 20h
le monde entier redoute le chaos au
pakistan compte ce soir 33 morts à la
suite des émeutes qui se sont
déclenchées après l'assassinât hier des
l'ex premier ministre benazir buttho des
milliers de ses partisans ont assisté
cet après midi à son inhumation dans le
caveau familial
c'est l'heure du retour pour les membres
de l'arche de zoé les six français ont
atterri il ya quelques minutes à peine
sur l'aéroport du bourget près de paris
un procureur de la république s'est
spécialement déplacé pour entendre les
condamner la justice française doit
maintenant déterminer la manière dont
ils purgeront leur peine qui doit fixer
la durée légale du travail en posant
cette question aux syndicats le
gouvernement a mis fin à la trêve des
confiseurs aujourd'hui force ouvrière
sud et la cgt dénoncent ce qu'ils
appellent une régression sociale majeure
selon la durée du travail ne peut pas
varier d'un salarié à l'autre même en
cas d'accord au sein des entreprises
un million et demi de personnes sont
attendus dans les gares parisiennes ce
week-end les grands départs pour la
deuxième semaine de vacances ont
commencé dès ce soir
suite et fin de la saga miss france
valérie bègue sera privé de concours
internationaux mais elle va pouvoir
garder sa couronne une couronne ébréché
dit ce soir la dame au chapeau qui ne
décolère pas et qui assure que le comité
miss france fera cette tournée l'année
prochaine sans l'élu 2008
on commence avec les obsèques de benazir
butto l'ex premier ministre du pakistan
assassiné hier a été inhumé tout à
l'heure dans son caveau familial devant
des milliers de ses partisans des
partisans qui hésite ce soit entre
douleur et colère
loïc de la mornais l'ambulance et la
dépouille de benazir bhutto ont mis deux
heures à fendre la foule
des centaines de milliers de personnes
venues accompagner ce cercueil enveloppé
du drapeau noir béret rouge du parti du
peuple pakistanais
comme le veut la tradition musulmane
l'ancien premier ministre et enterré
rapidement moins de 24 heures après sa
mort le mari de benazir bhutto qui porte
un chapeau religieux blanc est arrivé de
dubaï avec les trois enfants du couple
ce qui est arrivé est effroyablement
tragique
il faut bien réaliser que c'est la
quatrième personne de la famille bhutto
à être tué c'est une martyre et pour
cause
benazir bhutto est enterré dans ce
mausolée aux côtés de deux de ses frères
décédés dans des conditions obscures et
de son père ancien premier ministre lui
aussi pendu après un coup d'état
la politique a réuni le père et la fille
dans la mort au même moment les
enquêteurs annonçaient de nouvelles
informations
d'abord que les services de
renseignement avaient intercepté et
traduit une conversation téléphonique ou
un haut responsable d'al-qaïda félicite
un activiste après l'attentât ensuite
que benazir bhutto on n'aurait pas été
tué par balles le top 6 aurait montré
que son corps n'avait reçu aucun
projectile ni éclat images à l'appui
cette toute dernière vidéo on y perçoit
le souffle de l'explosion
c'est ce qui aurait tué l'ancien premier
ministre qui se serait mortellement
cogné la tête contre le toit de sa
voiture
une version démentie ce soir par un
proche collaborateur de bhutto affirmant
que la thèse du gouvernement est un
tissu de mensonges et assurant que
l'ancien premier ministre a reçu une
balle à l'abdomen et une dans la tête
pour l'heure cet assassinat peut-il
plonger le pays dans le chaos c'est une
crainte dans les équilibres politiques
et religieux sont fragiles au pakistan
pour l'heure rien n'a été décidé sur le
maintien ou non des élections
législatives le 8 janvier le président
musharraf n'a pas ordonné à l'état
d'urgence mais les forces de l'ordre ont
reçu l'autorisation de tirer à vue sur
les émeutiers des émeutes qui ont déjà
fait 33 morts dans le pays jérôme berlin
un déferlement de rats
propager en quelques heures dans les
bastions de benazir buttho d'abord dans
le sud à karachi ses partisans prennent
d'assaut les rues fou de colère dans
leurs slogans ils s'en prennent aux
islamistes un peu au président musharraf
beaucoup c'est un chien hurle au tilt
ils l'accusent de ne pas avoir assez
fait protéger benazir butto alors ils
s'en prennent aux alliés politiques du
général-président les bureaux de ce
député sont saccagés tout symbole du
pouvoir est pris pour cible il ya là un
foyer de violence et d'extrémisme majeur
dans un pays que je vous le rappelle à
la bombe atomique donc il est très très
essentiel que la stabilité du pakistan
où un semblant de stabilité ou le plus
de stabilité possible soit maintenu et
la france y sera avec l'union européenne
très attentive pour disperser la foule
du gaz lacrymogène pour l'instant mais
les forces militaires ont reçu l'ordre
de tirer à vue sur les émeutiers
seize mille policiers déployés encore
une fois pervez musharraf tient le pays
par la force
musharraf devient la dernière
alternative contre les islamistes est
donc en quelque sorte ils tirent
bénéfice de l'assassinât de benazir
butto mais en même temps c'est un échec
très grave pour les états unis dans la
mesure où benazir buttho était leur
carte maîtresse pour redonner un
semblant de stabilité et surtout un
semblant de pouvoir civil ce retour du
pouvoir civil était symbolisée par les
élections législatives prévues dans 10
jours
ce matin le premier ministre en exercice
a prétendu qu'elles seront maintenues
dans ces conditions de chaos
cela semble difficile à imaginer
et cette crainte du chaos concerne tout
le monde ce soir y compris dans les
communautés où benazir butto et est
considérée comme une adversaire
politique
notre envoyé spécial benoît bringer a pu
se rendre dans la ville de quetta
c'est d'un des siestes et
fondamentalistes pas très loin de la
frontière avec l'afghanistan
écoutez ce que l'on peut dire ce soir
c'est que la situation reste extrêmement
tendue sur l'ensemble du paquet ce temps
une tension que l'on a senti dans les
rues tout au long de la journée à coups
état où je me trouve l'un des fiefs
islamistes du pays
tous les magasins sont restés fermés par
respect du deuil national bien sûr mais
surtout par peur du vandalisme
la circulation a été interrompue et ce
sont surtout les militaires dont la
présence a été renforcée qui sont
visibles dans les rues en fait
l'essentiel de la population a préféré
rester chez elle à l'abri devant la télé
pour suivre les dernières informations
est ce que je peux vous dire c'est que
toutes les personnes que nous avons
rencontrées qu'elles soient supporters
ou pas de benazir bhutto expriment leur
inquiétude
elles craignent une vague de violence et
surtout désespère de voir un jour la
situation politique de leur pays
s'améliorer et benazir buttho n'était
pas seulement une opposante politique
elle était aussi un symbole d' par son
seul nom les buts aux sont une grande
famille du pakistan pourrait même dire
une dynastie maudite pour certains à 35
ans benazir avait dû reprendre le
flambeau de son père pendu par le régime
militaire
à l'époque elle nous avait ouvert les
portes de cet incroyable mausolée
familial qu'elle vient de rejoindre
aujourd'hui bernard lebrun la démarche
d'un flamand rose hill au caractère du
c'était il ya plus de vingt ans voici
que benazir l'héritière revient à
lakanal à 30,3 au l'arcana le fief de la
dynastie buteau où se trouve le mausolée
familial
hazard est destinée tragique ce jour
d'août 1986 benazir vient prier sur la
tombe de son frère
shawan has more cette année la rampe au
zoo propose aussi dans ce caveau murtha
sa mort assassiné en 1996 et bien sûr le
père ali bhutto anciens premiers
ministres exécuté par pendaison en 1979
par les généraux putschistes au nom du
père donc entouré de mort violente
benazir un prénom signifiant l'unique
langue pakistanaise s'apprêtait alors à
conquérir le pouvoir
sans esprit de revanche 17 heures si
j'avais voulu la justice pour ne pas
parler de revanche je serais allé voir
le peuple pour lui dire mon père a été
tué pour vous je viens vous demander
justice les gens répondu à mon appel
mais je n'ai pas fait destinée tragique
d'une femme de pouvoir qui incarne et la
démocratie
là même où benazir venait prier il ya 20
ans elle repose aujourd'hui à jamais le
reste de l'actualité les six français
membres de l'arche de zoé condamnés au
tchad viennent d'atterrir au bourget en
région parisienne et vous découvrez ici
le jumelage de l'arrivée de leur avion
tourner il ya quelques minutes à peine
sur plastique sont attendus par un
impressionnant dispositif policier tout
un dispositif mis en place pour
réceptionner ce transfèrement
elle ferme techniques juridiques qui
rappelle qu'il s'agit bien d'un
transfert de prisonniers puisque vous le
savez les membres de l'arche de zoé ont
été condamnés au tchad alors on va
retrouver bien sûr nos envoyés spéciaux
sur place au bourget mais en attendant
je vous propose de découvrir les
derniers pas des membres de l'arche de
zoé au tchad
c'était tout à l'heure avant qu'il ne
décolle envoyés spéciaux n'djamena
amaury guibert et frédéric ranque
en polo rouge eric breteau monte avec
difficulté la passerelle qui mène à
l'avion derniers instants au tchad avant
le retour en france pour les six membres
de l'arche de zoé
les détails de ce transfert ont été
réglés dans la matinée au rythme des
visites à la prison de niamey n'a ici le
consul de france qui s'est assuré de
l'état de santé des prisonniers
relatives aux biens à cet instant tous
les papiers sont prêts pour le transfert
dans la cour
eric breteau fume une cigarette à ses
côtés philippe van winkelberg le médecin
plus loin dominique aubry le logisticien
salue les gardiens une dernière fois
à 12h30 le fourgon cellulaire quitte la
maison d'arrêt pour gagner l'aéroport de
n'djamena emilie lelouch
eric breteau s'épaulent pour monter les
quelques marches qui mènent au pavillon
d'honneur derrière alain péligat et
nadia merimi est infirmière à la grille
il ya soit de sa soeur qui attend de
pouvoir l'avoir et le dire au revoir
voyant sa petite soeur régler mes notes
elle ne pouvait pas se maîtriser et donc
nadja de son côté et souad franchement
c'était poignant et selon moi qui va me
marquer peut-être toute ma vie après les
dernières formalités d'embarquement des
buts chacun des prisonniers menottés
escorté par un agent de l'administration
pénitentiaire française des gendarmes et
les officiel tchadien font aussi partie
du voyage
à 13h40
le boeing 737 de la compagnie toumaï air
tchad décolle enfin de l'aéroport de
n'djamena jusqu'au bout dans ce dossier
les susceptibilités tchadienne que
françaises auront été ménagé le fait
d'utiliser un avion tchadien ainsi
permis à n'djamena de garder la tête
haute
la france de son côté a obtenu ce que
son président a promis ramener à paris
les six membres de l'arche de zoé
oui cet avion vous l'avez vue est donc
arrivé il y à quelques minutes au
bourget le bourget où l'on retrouve en
direct notre envoyé spécial claude sans
père claude est ce que vous avez pu voir
les membres de l'arche de zoé est ce que
vous savez quelle va être leur parcours
judiciaire maintenant écouter à l'heure
actuelle les six membres de l'arche de
zoé se trouve toujours à l'intérieur de
l'aéroport du bourget vous savez cette
histoire jusqu'au bout elle restera
exceptionnelle
normalement il devait ensuite aller au
tribunal de grande instance de bobigny
pour être présenté un nombre du parquet
et finalement il ya moins d'une heure
tout a changé c'est le procureur en
personne qui s'est déplacé ici à
l'aéroport du bourget et qui à l'heure
actuelle est en train de rencontrer
individuellement les six membres de
l'arche de zoé
on a vu en moins d'une heure rentrer ici
non seulement un fourgon cellulaire mais
aussi des ambulances apparemment l'état
de santé de certains membres de l'arche
de zoé ne permettait pas leurs
transferts ce soir au tribunal de grande
instance de bobigny ensuite qu'est ce
qui va se passer va c'est simple ils
vont être conduits dans un centre
pénitentiaire dans la région parisienne
après rayons par le frêne s'est pas
confirmée officiellement mais c'est
l'hypothèse la plus vraisemblable
là ils seront vus par un médecin et le
médecin devra décider si on les place en
cellules ordinaires ou si on les place
en secteur hospitalier pénitentiaire ça
c'est ce qui se passe ce soir
ensuite la grande étape dans dix quinze
jours les six membres de l'arche de zoé
ils seront présentés devant un tribunal
et c'est ce tribunal correctionnel qui
devra décider qu'est ce qu'on fait de
cette peine qui a été prononcée au tchad
les huit ans de travaux forcés vous
savez bien évident que ça n'existe pas
en france
ces magistrats qui devront décider
comment donc on donne l'équivalent de
cette peine en france
ensuite vous savez qui a encore une
information judiciaire ouverte contre
les membres de l'arche de zoé en france
pour procédure d'adoption irrégulière
escroquerie en clair leur parcours
judiciaire en france ne fait que
commencer
merci claude et en attendant d'en savoir
plus sur les conditions dans lesquelles
ils vont devoir puis j'ai purgés
justement cette peine en france
revenons un instant sur ce que l'on a
appris durant ce procès au tchad
qu'est-ce qui est désormais avéré qu'est
ce qui ne l'est pas encore tout à fait
quelles sont les zones d'ombré qui
persistent dans ce dossier car il y en a
encore qui emménage y ait une
instruction bouclé en 6 semaines un
procès de quatre jours et à l'énoncé du
verdict des visages affligé et un fort
sentiment d'inachevé les pandas à huit
ans de camp rock français at on appris
au cours de ce procès pas grand chose
deux intermédiaires tchadiens auraient
dissimulé l'identité de certains enfants
à l'arche de zoé la justice tchadienne
ne croit qu'à moitié à cette thèse
elle condamne les français pour
tentative d'enlèvement eric breteau est
il plus responsables que les autres non
répond le juge la même peine pour tous
les français une sanction moins lourde
pour les intermédiaires tchadien qui
sont les 103 enfants de l'arche de zoé
les audiences ont permis de rétablir
l'histoire d'une cinquantaine d'entre
eux il serait tchadiens et non pas
soudanais la plupart auraient encore un
voire deux parents directs on est loin
des orphelins du darfour
l'opération était dès le départ ambiguë
et les explications tortueuse en est
sorti les enfants il également d'un pays
pour commencer pas du tout on les a pas
sorti du pays on les a amenés
c'est pas du tout la même chose ça veut
dire qu'on les a pas sorti du pays on
n'a pas transgresser les lois du soudan
a transgressé aucune que savaient les
autorités françaises
plusieurs semaines avant l'opération
eric breteau a été reçue au quai d'orsay
qui aurait tenté de le dissuader et
alerté la justice était suffisant et si
vous voulez qu'on fasse on met les
menottes à monsieur moto sorte qu'elle
paie sur quelle base quelles bases non
on a fait tout ce qui était en notre
pouvoir pour que ils ne mènent pas cette
opération sur le terrain pourtant
l'armée française a mis des avions à
disposition de l'arche de zoé ou plus
exactement de children rescue l'autre
nom de l'association
quelles conséquences pour les
humanitaires il y aurait encore 80 ong
sur place dans une région déjà instable
arche de zoé a créé à créer un problème
additionnel qui a été la perte de
confiance complète de la part des
populations tchadiennes
il va falloir qu'on recrée cette
confiance cela prendra du temps
au plus fort de la crise des
manifestants anti européens avaient
caillassé des convois humanitaires et en
colombie jamais l'espoir n'avait été
aussi proche et a priori ce n'est plus
maintenant qu'une question d'heures la
mission humanitaire pour récupérer les
trois otages qui doivent être libérés
par la guérilla s'apprête à décoller du
venezuela voisin nous envoyés spéciaux
frédéric franck et renaud bernard ont pu
assister aux derniers préparatifs
le plan de vol et précis de l'aéroport
de santo domingo au sud du venezuela
la délégation qui doit récupérer les
otages va rallier villavicencio en
colombie dans des appareils repeint aux
couleurs de la croix rousse de là les
farc doivent communiquer les coordonnées
secrète du point de rencontre dans la
jungle les familles des otages sont
arrivés hier soir à caracas
fébrile à quelques heures du dénouement
fin du monde quand besson bien que ce
n'est plus qu'une question d'heures
un peu nerveux parce que je vais
rencontrer pour la première fois ma
belle-mère et mais je suis content très
content à la première fois aussi pour la
maman de clara rojas
elle n'a pas revu sa fille depuis son
enlèvement avec ingrid betancourt le 23
février 2002 et elle n'a jamais connu
son petit fils emmanuel 3 ans nés en
captivité il est multi sim c'est
tellement important de voir ma fille et
puis je vais enfin voir mon petit fils
j'en ai tellement réveiller pour
commencer c'est un problème ancien je
suis super émue en attend ce jour depuis
tellement longtemps
on est super heureux convoqué par hugo
chavez
l'ex président argentin nestor kirchner
est arrivé lui aussi à caracas
l'équipe des observateurs internationaux
convoqués pour participer à l'opération
est au complet bien tous les comics the
do tous les représentants des
gouvernements qui ont été nommés pour
participer à cette opération
des médecins sont également du voyage
selon la croix-rouge clara rojas irait
bien
mais c'est moins sûr pour la
parlementaire consuelo gonzalez les
otages ne sont pas loin mais la colombie
n'a autorisé le survol de son territoire
par les appareils vénézuélien que
jusqu'à dimanche
ici tout le monde espère que les
prisonniers seront sortis de la jungle
avant cette date
l'actualité en france ce sont aussi les
départs en vacances aujourd'hui bison
futé voit orange dès ce soir en région
parisienne ce mardi pour l'heure ça
circule plutôt bien orange aussi dans le
sens de départs sur le plan national
pour demain et dans les gares la
situation n'est guère meilleure on
attend pour le week-end près d'un
million et demi de voyageurs au seul
départ de paris et vu la forme des
bagages qui fleurissent depuis quelques
heures sur les quais de la gare de lyon
la destination fait pas beaucoup de
doute yassine benzia net grégory vasseur
certains ont de drôles de bagages au
bout des quais la clusaz val thorens
des noms qui font rêver et un programme
chargé les batailles de boules de neige
et puis tu vas te reposer aussi beaucoup
donc quelques jours de vacances mais les
valises sont pleines à craquer
pour tout emmener les jouets les courges
et les affaires de style donc ça fait du
mal
quand vous êtes aussi chargé la bouffe
les affaires voilà prévu pour ce long
week-end du nouvel an un million et demi
de voyageurs sont attendus dans les
gares parisiennes dont 500000 rien qu'à
la gare de lyon trois minutes qui part
avec 1000 personnes à bord modo un tgv
c'est presque trois airbus a320 en
capacité d'en c'est comme si on avait
trois décollage l'airbus des 3000 un
train toutes les 3 minutes
mais pas question de rater le sien car
pour les retardataires
les s'il vous plaît ne changeront rien
il faudra patienter
c'est rageant mais
départ manqué pour certains retour
réussi pour d'autres quoi de plus
romantique qu'un baiser échangé sur le
quai d'une gare pendant les fêtes on
parle souvent de trêve des confiseurs en
politique est bien le lien apparemment
d'être rompu les syndicats dénoncent
aujourd'hui ce qu'ils considèrent comme
une tentative du gouvernement de mettre
fin à la durée légale du travail
force ouvrière sud et la cgt inquiète de
ce que cette durée puisse être demain à
fixer à la carte en fonction des accords
dans les entreprises s'insurge
aujourd'hui valérie le rouge christophe
la rocard lendemain de noël un peu
douloureux pour les syndicats dans une
lettre qu'ils ont reçu hier françois
fillon précise noir sur blanc des idées
de nicolas sarkozy pour assouplir la
durée du travail
autant d'idées rejeté en bloc il y a dix
jours par exemple privilégié des accords
d'entreprise pour déterminer la durée du
travail et même des accords directs
entre le salarié et l'employeur
inconcevable pour force ouvrière si
l'entreprise décidé de repasser à 40
heures vous re calcul y est les heures
supplémentaires au delà de 40 heures
alors c'est ça c'est ils veulent y aller
c'est des coups de butoir la important
quand la durée légale pour faire le
constat après demain comme on discute
entreprise par entreprise on l'imposent
entreprise par entreprise la durée
légale n'existe plus inutile d'agiter le
chiffon rouge répond le gouvernement ce
ne sont que des hypothèses de travail
c'est nadine décide rien c'est à dire
que dernière s'ouvre maintenant une
période de discussions avec les
partenaires sociaux
on va discuter de la durée du temps de
travail donc c'est absolument pas un
truc qu'on aurait cherché à faire passer
en catimini sous les tapis entre noël et
jour de l'an n'y a aucune décision
le gouvernement veut surtout en finir
avec une spécificité française 35 heures
imposées par la loi contre 37 en
allemagne ou au royaume-uni négocié par
secteur trente huit heures en espagne
jusqu'à 40 en pologne
autre objectif simplifier une
règlementation devenue trop pesante
quoi qu'il arrive quelles que soient les
décisions maintien discussions sur le
temps de travail
quoi qu'il arrive il faut que l'on
arrive un dispositif moins complexes
plus homogène
remettre à plat le temps de travail
c'est avant tout un souhait du patronat
laurence parisot l'a plusieurs fois
réclamé elle a désormais trois mois pour
en discuter avec les syndicats
difficile d'être ado un récent rapport
estime que 900 mille adolescents en
france se trouve en situation de grande
souffrance souffrance psychologique qui
peut parfois se traduire physiquement
parce que c'est bien connu lorsque les
mots ne peuvent être dit il et il se
transforme mon mot mahut x et c'est
pourquoi à paris un service de l'hôtel
dieu est spécialement dédié à cette
catégorie de patients
josé dans la pierre mathias barrois vous
avez rendez vous avec moi d'accord
alexandre a quinze ans et le médecin
scolaire qui l'envoie pour un bilan
pourquoi le médecin d'école vous est
demandé de venir me voir deux fois 1
je me sens fatigué tout ça et comme
toujours dina vernon va chercher à
comprendre questionnaire à l'appui
voulait tous types à l'enfance l'école
les soucis car ce qu'elle vise c'est
l'ado dans sa globalité
un ado dont elle doit d'abord gagner la
confiance nous a expliqué qu ici tout ce
qu'on verrait tout ce qu on se dirait
c'est totalement secrète car à 15 ans on
n'a pas honte de ces questions et nous
demandent est-ce que je suis normal
est-ce que je vais encore grandir
est ce que mes seins ma la forme de mon
corps mon visage
tout ce que j'aime pas est-ce qu'on
pourrait pas le changer les ados sont
ici chez eux un centre de santé où ils
viennent confier leurs problèmes de
sommeil mais aussi leur bakhtin leur
rage de dents leur chagrin d'amour ou
comme sarah sa grossesse à 17 ans quand
on sait pas trop qui est allé voir c'est
important pouvoir savoir qu'à des
endroits quelques des jeunes et sont
vraiment à l'écouté des ados que dina
vernant traite parfois comme ses propres
enfants
la sara j'étais pas bon tout ça ne me
fait pas
des garçons et des filles pas encore
adulte mais qui ne supporte plus d'être
pris pour des gamins les inquiétudes des
adultes ne sont pas les mêmes que les
inquiétudes des adolescents et nous dans
cette médecine de l'adolescence qui
n'est pas la santé mentale et qui est la
santé ou sens global du terme
nous y répondons à leurs questionnements
et premier temps nous les ratios en sept
ans plus de 4000 jeunes ont été suivis
dans cet espace où la médecine est un
tout celle du corps de l'esprit et du
social fin du suspense insoutenable
autour de la miss france 2008 elle va
garder sa couronne mais une couronne
ébréché dit ce soir la présidente du
comité madame de fontenay ne décolère
pas contre valérie bègue et faute de
pouvoir la détrôner elle a décrété
qu'elles seraient entre autres interdit
de gala à ses côtés cette année une
ambiance n'est peut-être pas une
mauvaise nouvelle pour miss france
nabila taboury lyonnais langlade une
heures de conciliabules entre geneviève
de fontenay et sa miss en sursis et
valérie bègue sort de la cohue
la larme à l'oeil mais les sharks bien
accroché geneviève a accepté qu'elle
conserve sa couronne mais tout la
condition qu'elle ne se présente pas aux
élections internationales les 9 millions
de téléspectateurs qui ont voté pour
miss réunion ont donc eu raison de la
colère de geneviève de fontenay oublier
les photos lascive label garde son titre
mais la vo la priver de concours miss
europe et miss monde pour sa part je
reste miss france c'est je garde je
viens de titres et ça ça compte beaucoup
à mes yeux je crois qu'il ya beaucoup
d'autres moyens de représenter la france
à l'étranger que parfait que par ses
concurrents internationaux
merci à tous autre conséquence pendant
quelques temps geneviève de fontenay
participera seul aux concours régionaux
de miss elle refuse pour l'instant
d'avoir valérie bègue à ses côtés dès la
parution des photos vendredi dernier
geneviève de fontenay avait réclamé la
démission de miss france 2008 une
semaine de forte agitation plus tard
quelqu'un lui rétif et manger son
chapeau au lancement
depuis une semaine les initiatives de
soutien miss france se sont multipliées
à la réunion son île natale jusqu'à ce
tee shirt d'un goût plutôt douteux tiré
à 300 exemplaires il risque de devenir
maintenant un collector c'est un des
casse-tête de l'année quelle carte de
voeux envoyé à qui comment dire autre
chose que le tout bête mais très
efficace bonne année il vous reste
quelques jours pour y réfléchir et pour
ceux qui n'ont pas vraiment d'idée en
voici quelques-unes julie vestel
mattioni vencovsky plus que trois jours
pour faire son choix
trois jours pour se décider entre les
cartes de voeux les plus traditionnels
ou les plus bariolés difficile de
trouver celle qui à coup sûr fera
plaisir
c'est le temps où on choisit une
il a 40
ans à la personne à dire je vais
l'écouter en cheville
déporté
dans cette boutique parisienne on est
résolument rétro
tous les modèles viennent des années 30
pourtant écrire une carte ce n'est pas
forcément vivre dans le passé je crois
que quand on écrit quand on prend le
temps quand on prend la peine de prendre
un stylo à une jolie carte c'est que
c'est du temps qui est consacré à une
personne je ne sais pas s'il ya autant
de bonheur dans un e-mail que dans une
jolie carte
malgré tout la carte virtuelle gagne du
terrain les français en sont les plus
gros utilisateurs en europe cette année
cinq millions d'entre eux enverront leur
carte par courriel et les jeunes ne sont
plus les seuls à adresser leurs voeux
sur internet tout le monde envoie des
cartes de voeux électroniques que ce
soit des adolescents des seniors des
particuliers dans un contexte personnel
professionnel
gl c'est un produit qui devient de plus
en plus universel avec l'internet à haut
débit
les cartes virtuelles se sont
perfectionnés ce sont désormais des
produits multimédia avec du son et des
animations pour 2008 en tout cas france
télévisions ménages toutes les
traditions des voeux sur papier ou sur
écran
et en parlant de en voici un formulée
par george bush lui même voeu pieux le
diront certains le président américain
voudrait que les sportifs de haut niveau
arrête de se doper
alors pourquoi cette prise de position
publique et bien tout simplement parce
qu'un rapport aux états unis vient de
jeter un pavé dans la mare comme on dit
il concerne le sport fétiche des
américains le baseball est là bas c'est
presque une religion
alain de chalvron il y a bien quelque
chose de pourri dans le monde du
baseball ce sport qui nous paraît ôter
rythmé qui passionne les américains plus
d'europe les joueurs paraissent un peu
grassouillet et n'ont pas l'air de se
fatiguer erreur il faut parfois courir
très vite
d'où la tentation de faire appel aux
produits dopants un rapport du très
respecté sénateur mitchell jette un pavé
dans la mare l'utilisation de stéroïdes
dont la ligue professionnelle de
baseball était très largement répandue
par la réponse des autorités sportives a
été lente et inefficace du moins au
début et n'affecte le rapport de 300
pages ressemblent à un rouge ou du gloss
ball professionnel 89 joueurs parmi les
plus connus appartenant à une trentaine
de clubs richissime sont épinglés
l'amérique qui faisait l'autruche est
sous choc jusqu'au plus haut niveau
j'en appelle ces athlètes qui sont sous
les projecteurs
qu'ils comprennent que lorsqu'ils jouent
avec leur santé il donne un bien mauvais
signal à notre jeunesse
voilà le baseball est le sport favori
des enfants
on joue dès l'âge de 5 6 ans et les
champions dont on sait aujourd'hui
qu'ils se droguent et à qui mieux mieux
on figure de modèle lorsque des gosses
nous demandent s'ils devraient prendre
de la créatine des trucs comme ça on les
envoie chez le kiné ou l'ambiance
l'amérique sportive a longtemps été
laxiste en termes de lutte contre le
dopage
elle découvre aujourd'hui une terrible
réalité 672 vie de ses enfants au moins
à vous utilisé des stéroïdes
on va parler maintenant d'une success
story comme disent les américains
tout le monde connaît les grands noms de
la mode française mais dans ce milieu
très fermé quelques petits créateurs
commence à se tailler une belle place il
reste luxe mais ne sont pas
inaccessibles
si des habits vous intéresse vous
connaissez déjà leur nom estelle colin
guillaume michel si elle bouge désormais
dans la cour des grands avec son premier
décidé elle est devenue l'icône de la
marque paul en jouant moins de 10 ans un
succès fulgurant tu comme celui du
discret thierry gillier double face et
d'ailleurs pas il fait confiance à
carole cécilia ces deux directrices
artistiques pour incarner sa griffe
d'indiquer voltaire trentenaire
parisienne raffolent de ces petits
cachemire plus penser à travailler qu'on
ne le croit en créer une mode que la
fille quand elle habille on s'est dit
que ça se voit pas quel est le miroir
il fallait alors un filin pu enfiler un
pantalon ces petits bottes sans blouson
en cuir et la fille belle moderne ne va
pas du tout chez paul and joe en
revanche ont misé sur le glamour
énergique obstiné il y a dix ans donnait
pas cher de la peau de sophie albou
aujourd'hui paul and joe paie 50
millions d'euros de chiffre d'affaires
on a eu des premiers proto qui était
très moche et on les a refait refus ont
fait jusqu'à arriver à un résultat qui
me plaît vraiment eu pas marché s'il te
plaît elle aura attendu trois longues
années pour que les acheteurs français
s'intéressent à ces créations et suédé à
l'époque paul and joe était de pauvres
styliste anglais aujourd'hui ces
nouveaux luxe est le vent en poupe
quand on passe devant leur vitrine on a
envie du vêtement que si on se dit pas
certain que je vais avoir envie
d'acheter pouvoir payer en tout cas dans
quatre mois ce sont des marques dont le
succès je crois est basé enraciné dans
une notion très forte de bon sens chacun
a su s'inventer une communication sur
mesure chez zadig et voltaire et le
bouche à oreille qui a créé le buzz
aujourd'hui on a les moyens d'une vraie
campagne de publicité fidèle à ses
valeurs il ya un peu trop artificiels
ont donné ce feeling de vérité non pas
de photos éternellement retouché est
trop trop sophistiqué plus portable un
peu moins cher c'est mars et qualifié
jusqu'à lors de moyenne gamme sont en
train de rivaliser avec les griffes de
luxe en france comme à l'étranger
si vous aimez les vieux livres a reçu
une bonne nouvelle certains sont
désormais disponibles aux presses
universitaires de france des copies bien
sûr cet éditeur et l'autorisation de
reproduire l'une des plus belles
collections privées du monde
françois jullien pieds-noirs mathias
second in principio créa wizdeo
non il ne s'agit pas du manuscrit du
davinci code non nous avons trouvé bien
mieux encore sur cette table à côté de
la bible de gutenberg imprimé au xvème
siècle
voici l'évangile selon saint-jean
conserver pendant 2000 ans par les
sables du désert
nous avons ici le trésor spirituel de
l'humanité ce qu est au fondement de
tout le christianisme c'est inestimable
nous sommes dans les entrailles de
genève à quelques mètres sous terre à
l'abri de la lumière et des changements
de température dans l'une des plus
belles collections au monde de livres
anciens
ici les premières éditions de
shakespeare côtoie un manuscrit de
goethe là une partition corrigé par la
main de ben et offre répond notes de
musique écrite à l'encré par mozart plus
loin un exemplaire du coran nous ouvre
ses plus belles pages daté du 10ème
siècle unique au monde
unique au monde comme le manuscrit des
120 journées de sodome rédigé par le
marquis de sade sur un rouleau de 12
mètres de long
chaque livre est soigneusement éclairé
sans uv les autographes avec langues
c'est ce qu'il ya de plus fragiles
puisque vous avec et dégradations sont
cumulatives et toute lumière finit par
les uv finissent par affaiblir
l'écriture elle même mais il ya des
manuscrits inestimable qui resteront
pour toujours dans l'ombre des
bibliothèques de riches collectionneurs
particuliers
c'est ce que ne voulait pas ce bibliobus
lille possède 4 mille livres dont le
carnet de voyage d'un soldat napoléon ce
qui a consigné toute la campagne
d'égypte des dessins en couleur et un
témoignage historique que seul ce
collectionneur pouvait lire chez lui
aujourd'hui le carnet est publiée à
l'identique en fac similé
le fac similé est quand même d'assez
bonne qualité et c'est de donner la
possibilité à un public plus large de
prendre connaissance et de lire dans le
texte
parce que c'est vraiment une
reproduction du texte est une
reproduction des planches
quelque chose qui est unique après notre
visite les volets se sont refermées le
collectionneur regard de ses livres dans
l'ombre non pas pour les cacher mais
pour les conserver c'est du feydeau
c'est du vaudeville il y a toujours
quelque part un petit bourgeois étouffé
par sa femme qui veut coucher avec celle
de son meilleur ami
clovis cornillac a endossé ce rôle
depuis hier soir au théâtre de la
colline à paris
la pièce s'appelle l'hôtel du libre
échange
abdelah mostefa chloé le compte sur
scène deux couples au bord de la rupture
tellement à bout que monsieur pong les
tons très bien sa chance avec madame
paillardes à la femme de son meilleur
ami
ça suffit de chronos moyens votre amant
parfaitement et 7 ans en théâtre apporte
clovis cornillac a enchaîné les
tournages pour le cinéma
sept ans sont le plaisir de faire des
cadeaux le soir de la première
représentation sept ans enclenche les 25
ans de carrière déjà et pour la première
fois le traque de celui qui se sait
attendu qu'on dise le pas bon et fasse
pas très grave
mes skis et ski ski me gênerait c'est de
prendre le dessus sur le pareil sur
spectacle sur le travail sur tout ce que
font la cama voici donc le sordide hôtel
du libre échange et son maître d'hôtel
des prix mais là encore visibles
régulier bien sûr
je vois ce soit monsieur petit nid
charmant jolie madame ça très bien
mignonne mais voilà j'ai prévenu la
récré d'avoir madame et raffarin nom qui
non non c'est monsieur qui passe du rire
et pas de morale chez feydeau il passe
de générosité a tout à coup une
méchanceté terrifiant que jai là il est
vraiment sur tous les saints paradoxe
total sans arrêt quoi donc effectivement
c'est si on enlève le rire ce que
l'humanité qui nous est montré les
terrifiants retournement de
personnalités et de situations tout est
possible y compris un thé dans un hôtel
de passe avec un vieil ami ses quatre
filles sortie du couvent et la maîtresse
qu'on n'a même pas pu cacher dans
l'armoire
vingt- ce journal je vous en rappelle le
principal titre l'ex premier ministre du
pakistan benazir buttho a été inhumé
aujourd'hui dans son caveau familial des
obsèques auxquelles ont assisté des
milliers de ses partisans
et pendant ce temps là dans plusieurs
grandes villes du pakistan les émeutes
se sont poursuivies au lendemain de cet
assassinat
on compte ce soir 33 morts dans tout le
pays c'est tout pour l'actualité de ce
vendredi tout de suite vous avez rendez
vous avec nathalie rihouet pour la météo
ensuite ce sera le tout dernier point
aux deux julien pascal ce soir sur
france 2 ce sera soit un polar avec pj
et avocats et associés excellente soirée
donc et puis pour ma part je vous dis à
demain dès 13h
l'info en continu c'est sur france 2
point fr